ein marathon ist mit 42 195 km die
längste olympische zulaufende distanz
jahr für jahr trainieren unfassbar viele
menschen besonders auf spektakel wie den
new york london boston oder berlin
marathon ist es aber möglich diese
unfassbare distanz und diese leistung
ohne erfahrung zu viel spaß wie schwer
ist es ein marathon ohne training zu
laufen
also ich weiß dass es nicht alle schloss
die idee ist und mir ist auch bewusst
dass das ziemlich ungesund ist also ich
meine die sportler die sonst marathon
laufen trainieren ja nicht ohne grund
mehrere monate oder sogar jahre
der grund warum ich das unbedingt machen
will ist eigentlich ganz einfach seit
einer gewissen zeit habe ich nicht mehr
das gefühl die ziele zu erreichen die
ich mir selber gesteckt habe und das
zehrt an meinem selbstbewusstsein und
wenn ich in so einer situation gefangen
bin in der ich das gefühl habe meinen
eigenen ansprüchen nicht gerecht zu
werden habe ich häufig das gefühl dass
es noch eine möglichkeit gibt da
rauszukommen eine aufgabe erledigen von
der niemand und auch selber ich nicht
denke dass ich sie schaffen kann eine
mammut aufgabe eben ganz dumm gesagt
wenn ich es schaffen kann ein super
hohes super schweres ziel zu erreichen
ist es mir möglich bin ich nach wie vor
gut genug um andere ziele zu erreichen
das hört sich alles schlimmer an als es
ist ich habe einfach im moment nicht das
gefühl dass ich die leistung bringe die
eigentlich bringen könnte das ist alles
dazu kommt dass wir dieses mal zum thema
schon sehr lange am herzen liegt und in
meinem kopf herumschwirrt und ich meine
freunde damit schon seit zwei jahren
belästigen ok aber was ist ein marathon
überhaupt ein marathon ist die längste
olympische laufdisziplinen mit 42 195
kilometern in youtube schoko hält mit
zwei stunden einer minute um 39 sekunden
den weltrekord und läuft somit eine
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von 21 km h
außerdem ist ja schon ein marathon in
unter zwei stunden gelaufen was lange
zeit als unmöglich galt das wurde
allerdings nicht als weltrekord gewertet
da das nicht unter wettkampfbedingungen
stattgefunden die durchschnittszeit bei
männern ist vier stunden 29 um 52
sekunden also mehr als doppelt so lang
die der lauf von elisa und auch das ist
schon sehr sehr schnell ich peile
erstmal überhaupt keine zeit an bei mir
geht es nur darum das ding fertig zu
laufen was schon aufgabe genug sein
sollte genug geredet lasst uns einmal
verlaufende strecke hier in köln
ausgesucht die durch einen grüngürtel
führt das sind genau 3,8 km
das bedeutet ich muss die strecke etwas
über elf mal ablaufen um auf die 42
kilometer zu kommen weil er erst da habe
ich es leider noch diesen rucksack haben
denn da sind getränke ladekabel für
diese kopfhörer und so drin
ist das zu einem kumpel der direkt in
der nähe von der strecke wohnt damit ich
nicht in 18 kilometern keine mucke mehr
auf den ohren habe oder nichts trinken
kann
deswegen habe ich mir auch diese strecke
ausgesucht habe freunde die ersten
ritter jetzt wo ich habe meinen ersten
kilometer geschafft und konnte den
rucksack mittlerweile abgeben das
bedeutet wir haben einen zettel
geschafft aber ich bin schon ganz fertig
und außerdem windows ab und zu sehr
stark macht nicht unbedingt leichter so
die ersten vier kilometer sind rum ich
werde mich ein paar mal öfter aus der
aufstellung melden und jetzt hat der
ersten moment eingesetzt wo ich merke
dass ich mich komplett überschätzt habe
bzw die leistung komplett unterschätzt
habe und ich schon deutlich fertiger bin
als ich gedacht hätte
eigentlich wollte ich den gesamten
grünen gipfel entlang laufen ich hatte
dabei aber nicht bedacht dass avaya web
bergauf geht deswegen lege ich jetzt
hier macht nach weimar um auf die andere
richtung mieterin grüngürtel und die
ersten acht kilometer also ein fünftel
der strecke sind geschafft ich merke das
ist das filmen mich immer komplett aus
dem flow bringt und ich deswegen schon
deutlich weniger filme als vorher
außerdem fühlt sich an wie eine ewigkeit
die schon unterwegs bin und ein wirklich
wirklich wirklich unerreichbares ziel
ich muss wirklich gegen meinen inneren
schweinehund ankämpfen und habe wirklich
durchgehend negativen gedanken wenn wir
zu 90 prozent sicher dass wir bereits
die erste klasse gelassen habe das ist
so unfassbar schmerzen druck
er ist ja langweilig im grüngürtel
deswegen bin ich ja zu einer stadt
unterwegs und laufe einfach durch
irgendwelche kasten so meine allererste
pause ich habe unendlichen hunger ich
probiere nicht stehen zu bleiben und das
im laufen zu lassen mittlerweile habe
ich wirklich kein bock mehr alles tut
weh ich glaube meine füße sind komplett
voll mit blasen wenn ich aber stehen
bleiben
dann bricht sofort ab glaube ich
ich habe alles auf gegessen und
getrunken ich muss ehrlich sagen meine
motivation ist komplett am boden
es tut alles weh ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass ich schaffen kann weil ich
habe weniger als die hälfte also ich hab
gerade genau 20 kilometer gerade wo ich
alles aufgegessen habe ich mich einfach
wirklich nicht danach als du dir jetzt
nochmal loslaufen und dasselbe und noch
ein bisschen mehr jetzt noch mal machen
muss ich sagen dass ich nicht damit
gerechnet hatte dass mein größtes
problem irgendwelche blasen oder
schmerzen an den beinen sein werden aber
momentan ist so dass wirklich die
schmerzen den allergrößten teil aus
bringen
ich konnte mich dazu durchgerungen
ich muss weiter
soundtrack und plötzlich ist etwas
extrem was passiert ich hatte wirklich
das gefühl keinen meter mehr
weiterlaufen zu können und vom einen auf
den anderen moment aber ich komplett
vergessen dass sich am laufen bin und
ich bin 13 kilometer gelaufen ohne davon
irgendwas zu merken rückblickend weiß
ich gar nicht mehr woran nicht gedacht
habe ich kann mich wirklich an fast gar
nichts erinnern und es war wie in trance
oder wie im drogenrausch und ich konnte
herausfinden dass das ein bestätigtes
phänomen ist dass sich runner's high
nennen außerdem hat sich in den ersten
20 kilometern sehr gewundert dass ich
nicht geschwitzt habe das sollte sich
aber jetzt also ich melde mich ganz kurz
aus dem schnitt das video ist wie immer
mehr aufwand geworden als ich jemals mit
gerechnet hätte außerdem war es
offensichtlich relativ anstrengend wenn
ihr das also support lassen wie die und
leicht da ich wünsche euch weiterhin
viel spaß mit dem video
ja ich entschuldige mich vielmals für
diese szene aber ich wollte euch ein
möglichst reales bild zeigen und das ist
eben bei kilometer 32 oder 33 passiert
an dem punkt war ich wirklich so fertig
dass sich kurz vorm heulen war und das
gefühl hatte zusammenzubrechen problem
an der sache war dass ab da das ziel
quasi vor meinen augen war weil es nur
noch zehn kilometer zu laufen waren ich
aber wirklich wirklich das gefühl hatte
nicht mehr einen einzigen meter laufen
zu können ich hab dann max angerufen und
der hat mich nochmal auf gewohnt hat und
ich bin erst mal drei bis vier kilometer
normal gelaufen also nicht geschockt
ich habe seit ca 5 km schon so das
gefühl dass ich so schüttelfrost
mir geht die ganze zeit übel kalt also
ich gebe mich fast davon aus dass ist
hiernach krank werden also wirklich ich
bin jetzt schon fünf mal über die grenze
gegangen weil ich dachte es geht gar
nicht erweitern jetzt ist es wirklich so
dass ich laufe zwar aber in 3 km h
geschwindigkeit und damit komme ich
heute nicht so selten paar kilometern
das problem dass meine zehen so komplett
verkrampfen also wenn das hier meine
zehen sind dass sie die ganze zeit so
zugehen damit zehn gehen nur bis hier
weil die komplett eingerollt sind laufe
seit zwei kilometern schritttempo gefühl
habe jetzt muss ich durchziehen aber
eigentlich fühlt sich mein körper macht
zusammenbrechen
der kampf zieht hier gerade so ein
bisschen das die wahrheit die ganze zeit
angespannt ist nachdem ich das jetzt ein
bisschen gedehnt mich spielt uns ein
wunder wieder zumindest ein bisschen
nachlassen nicht schnell und der fuß
auch aber noch ein bisschen verkrampft
aber zumindest wieder ein bisschen sechs
kilometer noch mitkommt
[Musik]
als ich das ziel dann wirklich vor augen
hatte habe ich gedacht dass es cool
wären die leute vom trip daran teilhaben
zu lassen und ich habe ein livestream
gestartet deswegen entschuldige bitte
die qualität wenn ihr aber lust habe bei
einem touchscreen dabei zu sein ist rime
eigentlich fast jeden morgen zwischen 11
und 12 uhr der link ist in dem video
beschreibung ich glaube es sind nur noch
so zirka 500 meter jetzt oder so
dieses gebäude ist mein ziel
[Musik]
eine woche ist vergangen nachdem ich den
marathon bestritten habe mir nach wie
vor unfassbar happy das gemacht zu haben
und noch viel hab ja dass ich es
geschafft habe
holt euch aber noch ganz kurz was über
die spätfolgen sagen also ich konnte
drei tage danach quasi nicht laufen
meine füße waren voll mit blasen meine
knie haben lee getan und deswegen möchte
ich euch sagen macht das nicht eure
körper können so etwas leisten mit genug
training sie sind aber nicht dafür
ausgelegt von null auf hundert sowas zu
machen das habe ich auch gemerkt ich
habe während des laufens schüttelfrost
gehabt ich hatte nach dem laufen
beinschmerzen des todes und
gelenkschmerzen meine füße waren voll
mit blasen und alles in allem ist es
einfach nichts was man ohne training
machen trotzdem irgendwie nice das
gemacht zu haben und natürlich happy das
ist geschafft hat ich bedanke mich immer
ist das ihr bis hierhin dran geblieben
sein lassen wie die online kommentar da
was ich als nächstes machen soll
abonniert damit ihr kein video mehr
verpasst ich bedanke mich vielmals war
wirklich wieder fucking auch wenn nicht
mal von der und checkt wirtschaft ach ja
nur liebe jetzt bis zum ende dran
geblieben sind bekommen meine zeit also
ich habe fünf stunden 6 minuten und 29
sekunden gebraucht und ich blende diese
bildchen nicht einen um auf zehn minuten
zu strecken sondern wirklich weil es mir
sehr wichtig ist euch davon zu erzählen